death is the enemy the first enemy and
the last the enemy fall was wings
and we still need to fight
you're scared aren't you what he's got
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys feet here this is going to be
my Game of Thrones Season seven episode
6 trailer breakdown this will obviously
contain spoilers for everything that's
happened in Game of Thrones through
season 7 episode 5 so if you're not
caught up you're going to want to stop
watching so we're going to go through
all the shots basically a frame by a
frame look at what we saw and then we'll
have the discussion afterwards about
what we've learned about the upcoming
episode so the trailer opens with a shot
of Jon north of the wall and we hear a
voiceover from bear he says death is the
enemy then we see the group guys walking
across the landscape looks pretty
amazing up there as we see them from the
front we see that the Hound of leading
them and we get this shot of them
looking on we see that it's the mountain
that shaped like an arrowhead that we
heard about in the hounds vision and the
flames so that has been a mystery with
different series going around but we can
see that it was just some mountain up
north that no one really knew about
until they caught their the voiceover
picks up again and Barrack says the
first enemy and the last we get a quick
flash over to the map room at
Dragonstone where tyrion is watching
Daenerys looking out the window we see a
shot of Tyrion who's deep in thought he
turns to Daenerys who looks like she has
to make a decision there's really no
other clues here so we'll just say that
that's what's going on for the moment
the voiceover is still going it says the
enemy always wins and we see an
important shot of Jon spinning around I
say it's important because it marks the
time of the other events I think as he
does we see the white army coming in
their direction they're sort of coming
through a cut there and there are a lot
of then we see Barrack actually speaking
and the voice-over picks up and we still
need to fight them
so the entirety of it is death is the
enemy the first enemy and the last the
enemy always wins and we still need to
fight him so it's pretty prophetic I
guess you could say I mean he's talking
about the
fact that they don't really have a
chance but they still have to take on
the enemy anyways we see our band of
Fighters taking a defensive position and
then we cut to an outside shot of
Winterfell and we hear Aria do a
voiceover that says you're scared aren't
you as she's saying this we see Sansa
closing a door and the voice-over
continues to say what are you scared of
as she sees this we see shots of the
Hound Jorah and the rest of the bunch
and then we see a white attack there's a
shot of the hound and torment beating
them down winner is here flashes between
the cuts and bold letters and put Game
of Thrones fought we see Jon class with
one of the White Walkers which is
interesting because of the fact that we
don't see his sword destroy the White
Walkers weapon we see one of Gendry
putting his Warhammer to good use then
we get a quick scene where it's a little
bit hard to tell what's going on but
it's probably the Nights Watch brothers
running towards the gate to open it with
torches you can't really make out who
this is or what's going on but in the
context of everything we've seen it
seems most likely that would be them
opening the gate for someone who's
coming back we see arya and salsa arias
kind of staring her down this is
probably in relation to the voiceover
but also in relation to that scroll we
saw Arya take from Littlefinger in the
last episode then we cut to the iconic
shot of Barrack with his flaming sword
again
from the winner is here trailer there
are a horde of White's coming into the
opening and at first when I looked at
this like I thought it was the night
king they were following but if you look
closely it actually looks like it's Jon
running away this ties into that shot
earlier I said that might be important
where he first sees them and it looks
like they descend on him right away like
he almost gets ended right there I can't
tell for sure but it looks like it's
that same scene just from a different
angle you know what I mean the
continuation of that from a different
angle
we then see him running and find out
what that was all about we saw this a
couple times in the trailers
we see the shot where torment comes in
behind him they're all running in the
distance we can see others also still
there going which all leads me to
believe that this is the very beginning
of the battle like when we saw John turn
he wasn't doing anything so I think this
is where they're being attacked and they
end up going towards that little bit of
higher ground to take the defensive
position of course we can't be sure
because it's a little bit screwy and
then the one thing where they're cutting
back and forth where we see them all up
on top of that or what we assume is up
on top of that they look like they're
just waiting like it's not happening
right at that moment so it's hard to
tell but anyways we do see people
running in the background and then we
get the big night Kings entrance we see
one of the other white walkers on
horseback they're on the field and if we
look behind him we see there's a ton of
other activity on that hill or incline
or what everyone calls behind it it's
not easy to say what he's looking at in
front of him and I don't think anything
in this trailer really gives us a firm
answer to that question so then it fades
to black and we end right there first of
all it goes without saying that this
looks like crazy trailer and we pretty
much expect that from the season's
penultimate episode it seems like
they've laid the groundwork now for
what's going to happen post the big
battle that we're about to see as in
they're supposed to catch one of these
whites and take it to King's Landing to
show it to Cersei so that'll be like the
finale stuff it was expected to be that
way anyways from what we saw from the
filming so this is going to be mostly a
battle beyond the wall episode which
looks pretty freakin amazing a couple
things that stood out right away for a
lot of different people that I've seen
commenting about this one was that the
Hound is swinging a hammer in that first
shot where we see him hit that white a
lot of people are saying well is that
ginjuries Warhammer he came back into
the series to go north of the wall and I
don't think we could say that for sure I
did look at both of the screen shots and
you can't tell for sure but it kind of
seems like in the way that it's set up
that this is a first encounter of course
that can be completely misleading but
thing I was thinking about after the
fact was is Disney need dragonglass for
something like weren't they going to
build weapons and go up there and use it
so the reason why he's using something
we're not used to seeing him uses could
be because it's a dragonglass weapon I
don't know I mean honestly when we see
gentry later using his hammer it's
clearly his hammer which doesn't make a
lot of sense and then you have Barrack
fighting with his sword so I'm not
really sure what they're maybe they just
don't understand what's going on yet but
hitting them with a regular hammer and
hitting them with the regular sword
shouldn't really be the most effective
way to fight this battle and John seemed
to know that with his whole wanting to
get dragonglass so who knows what's
going on with that either way I don't
think we see real evidence that Kendra
is going to die
I think someone's going to die the odds
are way too stacked against them for
everyone to come back but I don't think
it shows us here who that's going to be
I mean that you know you could kind of
look through the thing and see that some
people have way less of a chance to
survive than others like I don't think
John's going to die Gendry seems a
little bit safer than those since he
just came back Soros and barrack of kind
of fulfilled their role in a way they
went north they've got the hounds have
his Redemption arc so I'd say they're
the ones that are least likely to live I
also brought that up in my hound in the
Lord of Light video about how Barrett
goes he does have a kiss of life what we
think he does because before he died in
the books he passed that on to Lady
Stoneheart so there is some stuff there
if he dies though does that mean
Thoreau's has to be dead first because
Thoreau's is the one that brings him
back so the one thing I know for sure is
if some of these guys are going to die
let me know in the comments who you
think they are we can see that they are
building up some tension between Sansa
and Arya now that we know that
Littlefinger was basically setting them
up with the scroll that he wanted from
maester wolkan instead of like looking
for something to hide we'll see how that
plays out some but really I don't expect
that we'll see too much outside of this
battle and we see a glimpse of Daenerys
she may want to get involved because it
was pretty obvious that she had feelings
about John leaving when he left
in the last episode and I made a whole
video about that so that's probably
going to be hinted at some more maybe
she will take off and join the fight
obviously a lot of people are theorizing
that that's going to be an equalizer
which it looks like they're in pretty
bad shape there absolutely I could see
that happening I don't think we'll see
much King's Landing we didn't see much
in of anything here they're probably
going to be holding steady waiting to
see what happens and Winterfell I think
we'll get you know ten minutes maybe 15
minutes of what's going on with them the
cat-and-mouse game the chess game that
will be going on between Arya and
Littlefinger with Sansa sort of stuck in
the middle so I would think everyone's
most excited about this battle north of
the wall what else are you excited about
to see in the next episode the barrack
voiceover was just awesome it really set
the tone of what's going on here what do
you think the one's all about like she
says you're scared aren't you what are
you scared of now do you think she's
proposing the idea of taking out
Littlefinger and that's why she's asking
asan since were heed or scared or
whatever I'm not really sure it could be
like some creative cuts to throw us off
but obviously things are coming to a
head with Littlefinger and Santa and the
rest of her family
what about Jorah I mean is he going to
die north of the wall it kind of seems
unlikely to like he went all the way to
get his greyscale cured and then they're
just going to knock him off up there so
yeah I don't know I think they're kind
of pointing us in the direction of the
Lord of Light followers not making it
back but we'll have to see it should be
a high-octane
experience it should be really one
memorable episode I mean if the field of
fire 2.0 is anything to set us up for
what this would be like you know this is
I think we're going to all be pretty
satisfied but tell me what you guys
think in the comments make sure you like
the video if you enjoyed it the official
title of episode six hasn't been
announced yet officially so I'll go
ahead and add that into the title once I
find out what it is it's still just a
placeholder on the website right now so
I don't know for sure but yeah chime in
below let me know what your thoughts are
make sure you subscribe to my channel if
you haven't already set notifications so
you know when new videos come out I'm
doing a full schedule there'll be plenty
coming out this week follow me on
twitter like my facebook page follow my
instagram you know you can find out
there when new videos are out thanks for
watching guys I'll talk to you soon